[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono sicuro mi state chiedendo cosa
avete appena visto
e cos'è questo oggetto al kg sulla
fronte quello che vedete su questo
schermo è stato realizzato direttamente
con la mia mente e rappresenta
esattamente la strizza che si ferma
prima di salire su questo palco ed è
stato generato attraverso questo
dispositivo che è un'interfaccia neurale
ovvero un sistema che permette di
connettere direttamente il cervello e il
mondo che ci circonda e la tecnologia
che ci circonda ed è stato possibile
farlo grazie ad algoritmi specifici che
ci permettono di connettere direttamente
quello che stiamo immaginando pensando
alla tecnologia circostante sono sicuro
che adesso in realtà voi state pensando
a qualcosa di questo tipo
scherzi a parte è stata sicuramente
pensando a dispositivi piene di cavi
elettrodi cuffie qualcosa che si
utilizza oggi tutti i giorni in medicina
e nei campi di ricerca che però grazie
all'evoluzione tecnologica è riuscita a
trasformarsi a diventare di così piccole
dimensioni è così basso costo da poter
essere integrati in diversi settori di
applicazione
sono dispositivi questi che attraverso
piccoli sensori riescono a captare
l'attività elettrica del cervello cioè
quei piccoli impulsi che i neuroni
utilizzano per scambiarsi informazioni e
con degli algoritmi specifici e
complessi e possibile in qualche modo in
tre interpretare queste informazioni
ora so benissimo che è stata immaginando
film serie tv scenari apocalittici
stregonerie varie e sono sicuro che
state pensando a una cosa ben precisa
controllare oggetti col pensiero
di solito nei nelle mie speech mi
chiedono ma quindi è possibile far
levitare ad esempio una pallina col
pensiero abbiamo deciso quindi oggi di
darmi una dimostrazione di questo
proverò a far lievitare una pallina col
pensiero
mi dispiace ma non si può fare non si
può fare in realtà
è una mezza bugia si potrebbe fare si
potrebbero fare diverse cose oggi japy
lottiamo comandiamo veicoli riusciamo a
pilotare droni far volare droni magari
accende le luci ma è realmente questo lo
scopo delle neuro toccano neuro
tecnologie è davvero utile comandare
qualcosa distanza se non in particolare
i casi o per particolari patologie
finalmente questo lo scopo che ci
dobbiamo aspettare
se io voglio accendere una luce era
utilizza un interruttore se voglio
accendere la tv utilizzo il telecomando
quindi in realtà non è questo e non deve
essere questo il vero scopo delle neuro
tecnologia
no non possiamo neanche controllare
un'altra mente come non possiamo neanche
iniettare un nuovo concetto all'interno
del cervello di qualcuno sarebbe bello
poter andare all'università così no no
sono dispositivi di fatto passivi
dispositivi che ci permettono soltanto
di
attingere informazioni recuperare dei
dati grazie
di recuperare dei dati e no non parliamo
di leggere nel pensiero o rubare pin
password di carte di credito
anche perché vorrei sapere quanti di voi
ricordano memoria tutte le password no
riusciamo a capire lo stato mentale
istante per istante di una persona di
una persona ha detto non possiamo andare
a comprendere lo stato mentale degli
animali né sapere se il vostro gatto vi
odia o sta meditando di uccidervi quindi
sicuramente adesso mi chiederete va bene
ok quindi queste informazioni quali sono
torniamo un attimo al quadro astratto
che avete visto un attimo fa questo
quadro è costituito da forme linee
colori sfumature che sono tutte
riconducibili direttamente
scientificamente a quegli attimi prima
di salire su questo palco ed è possibile
farlo grazie al fatto abbiamo sviluppato
negli ultimi anni specifici e complessi
algoritmi
algoritmi che abbiamo reso sempre più
complessi e basati su 100 anni di studi
neuroscientifici fino a riuscire a
comprendere preziose informazioni
durante l'attività che una persona
svolgere queste informazioni
alcune di queste informazioni possono
essere lo stato di concentrazione di una
persona il livello di sonnolenza che una
persona durante l'esecuzione di un
compito il livello di affaticamento
mentale
l'attenzione ma soprattutto lo stress
mentale stress inteso come quella
condizione sensazione che si prova
quando siamo svolgendo un compito
cognitivamente difficile ovvero quando
percepiamo magari una sorta di
affaticamento mentale
durante l'esecuzione del compito oppure
quando questo compito reperiamo
difficile perché abbiamo sonno o ancora
perché non abbiamo abbondante esperienza
per riuscire a elaborarlo in maniera
semplice
qui dobbiamo pensare a questi sistemi a
questi dispositivi come dia di fit bit
non connessi direttamente al cuore ma al
cervello della persona quindi dei
fichtner struck che ci tengono informati
istante per istante di come la nostra
mente sta
per capire quanto sono importanti queste
informazioni
ho portato alcuni dati dal supporto
pensate che il 70 80 per cento degli
errori durante gli interventi chirurgici
è dovuto proprio all'affaticamento
mentale sì perché i chirurghi durante i
turni incessanti
accumulano 80 di quella fatica che di
conseguenza tendono ad aumentare ad
andare oltre i propri limiti senza che
se ne accorgano abbiamo condotto uno
studio in emilia romagna in un ospedale
attraverso questi dispositivi su
chirurghi
questo grafico
estratto proprio da questo studio e vede
una linea rossa che
rappresenta una metrica che definiamo
alfa prevale ovvero una m a che in
qualche modo sintetizza la fatica
mentale accumulate accumulata durante
una serie di compiti in questo caso
durante interventi chirurgici dal primo
al settimo e ultimo della giornata
se dal terzo al sesto questa fatica si
aumenta quello che balza all'occhio di
fatto è l'ultimo intervento il settimo
dove questa metrica vola verso l'alto
cosa significa questo che il chirurgo
accumulato una fatica enorme
durante l'ultimo intervento una fatica
che di conseguenza porta con sé una
probabilità maggiore terrore
i risultati non sono solo questi
possiamo citare il 21 per cento dei
dell'incidente aereo dovuto alla fatica
mento mentale oppure 36 per cento degli
errori nel controllo del traffico aereo
dovuto proprio all'affaticamento mentale
o al 33 per cento delle morti in mare
dei suv
indovinate a che cosa è dovuto proprio
ad affaticamento mentale e potrei
continuare così il punto qual è che
solitamente
si associa a questi incidenti l'errore
umano e quindi si fa presto a dire è
stata colpa dell'uomo in realtà non è né
colpa né l'uomo né della sua mente
il problema sta nei processi ovvero
quella sequenza di operazioni
collegate tra di loro che ci permettono
poi di elaborare un compito di
sviluppare un prodotto di erogare un
servizio
processi che sono stati messi magari in
piedi da un'azienda decenni e decenni fa
non tengono conto
di come una persona un gruppo di persone
interagisca all'interno di un contesto
interagisca all'interno di quel processo
non tengono conto dei limiti di ciascuna
persona perché ogni persona è diversa
l'una dall'altra sono processi che non
tengono conto neanche del momento
storico che si vive oggi vediamo una
crescente richiesta di
di
qualificazione un aumento costante
dell'automazione una crescente
competizione
non tengono conto di nulla di ciò ma
perché sono stati fatti dieci anni fa
non sono stati mai riprogettati sulla
base di quelle informazioni e il
problema dei processi non è legato solo
a al mondo lavorativo perché anche nella
sfera personale nella quotidianità o
nello studio non siamo in grado di
sviluppare un processo in maniera
corretta
non riusciamo a comprendere qual è la
nostra dimensione faccio un esempio la
pausa la pausa potrebbe sembrare un
concetto banale ma in realtà deve essere
concepita affinché non portino e noi a
nessuno lenza che riesca a prevenire un
sovraffaticamento c'è la pausa deve
essere letteralmente progettata sulla
base anche del lavoro che stiamo
svolgendo e quindi non siamo in grado né
lavorativamente parlando nella
quotidianità non siamo in grado di
comprendere la nostra dimensione dei
quali sono i nostri limiti e se stiamo
superando quei limiti e non è possibile
farlo perché fino a poco fa era
impossibile andare a misurare queste
informazioni
che alvin diceva che se qualcosa è
misurabile allora si può migliorare oggi
si può fare neuro tecnologie servono
realmente questo a misurare quelle
informazioni a riprogettare rimodulare
riconsiderare da zero quei processi al
fine proprio di evitare disastri
incidenti e quindi vittime
quello che vedete qui è un ragazzo un
campione di formula 3 e sta indossando
una sorta di fascia tergisudore
durante una fase di simulazione in gara
in realtà quali non era una fascia
tergisudore è un altro interfaccia
neurale sì perché tutto quello che ho
raccontato fino ad oggi è possibile
grazie al fatto che riusciamo stiamo
riuscendo a miniaturizzare sempre di più
questi dispositivi e utilizzarli tutti i
giorni in diversi settori senza che
magari lo sappiate questo è uno dei
tanti le applichiamo nella formula 1
le applichiamo nel marketing negli sport
negli sport virtuali nel gaming nel nei
trasporti li applichiamo nei luoghi di
lavoro per la sicurezza nei luoghi di
lavoro
tra qualche anno riusciremo addirittura
a tatuare questi sistemi sulla pelle non
vi spaventate parlo di tatuaggi che
vanno via con l'acqua come quelli che
uscivano dalle patatine un tempo
oppure riusciremo ad integrarli nei
dispositivi che utilizziamo auricolari
per fare col video call o ascoltare la
musica che usiamo tutti i giorni
qui dovremmo immaginare un mondo in cui
queste tecnologie sono connesse
direttamente al nostro cervello il
cervello e la nostra mente al centro di
tutto e scambia costantemente dati con
la tecnologia che ci circonda una
tecnologia che riesce così a comprendere
esattamente come ci sentiamo istante per
istante momento per momento e quindi che
cosa fa tecnologia in questo caso riesce
a modularsi a modellarsi di conseguenza
quindi a capire come ci sentiamo quindi
possiamo definire in qualche modo una
tecnologia empatica ora se questo vi
sembra un po troppo black mirror
facciamo così facciamo un passo indietro
torniamo a qui chirurghi di primavalle
ricordate
immaginiamo di essere uno di quei
chirurghi che ormai arrivato al settimo
e ultimo intervento chirurgico
però a questo punto sappiamo esattamente
la fatica che abbiamo accumulato
ok come ci sentiremmo adesso ad operare
l'ultimo paziente
quindi non dobbiamo spaventarci non
dobbiamo avere paura di mettere la
nostra mente
al centro di tutto anzi dobbiamo
raggiungere come scopo quello di
riuscire ad auto controllarci all'auto
monitorarsi riuscire a superare i nostri
limiti in maniera sana ad aumentare le
nostre performance mentali ad aumentare
le nostre capacità mentali e starà un po
come avere dei superpoteri quindi in una
sola frase dobbiamo riuscire ad imparare
ad ascoltare la nostra mente grazie
[Applauso]